you're known for not only being very
caustic but obviously being very
religious so what is your religious
background i'll get into religion a
little bit more deeply a little bit
later in the in the show but what's your
religious background what's your belief
system yeah i'm catholic so i grew up
very catholic very conservative catholic
uh i've got you know five brothers and
sisters and my one of my sisters is a
nun now so that's the kind of catholic
family that we have
um and but i grew up in a very kind of
liberal area going to public school so
you had to
you know your parents had to instill in
you the ability to defend
not just the ability to defend your
beliefs but also um the willingness and
and sort of finding joy in that argument
uh so i think that's kind of where i got
it from and how did all of this impact
on your politics so you're a
conservative obviously uh you were not a
super pro trump conservative during
2016. so how does your world view shape
your political views
um well
you know for me the
the the first objective for for everyone
is to is to get to heaven right that's
that's the first objective is our is our
spiritual uh fulfillment so
that to me is is number one before you
get to to politics or anything like that
um and this is
you know one of the problems i see in
the conservative movement now is uh i
don't it seems like it's not really
grounded in anything um like maybe it
used to be grounded in those deeper kind
of spiritual moral truths
um so i think it's got to be kind of
ground ground up from there like what
are your what do what are your
fundamental beliefs like what and that
is why are we here what's the point of
life what's the point of any of this i
think those are the questions you have
to be able to answer and then once you
can answer those questions
then you sort of build your political
framework on top of that so from a
religious point of view and you say that
the goal is to get to heaven
are you a belief-based person i mean is
it is it that you believe in in christ
and therefore you go to heaven or is it
a works-based thing because obviously
this is sort of a differentiator between
judaism and christianity in some
iterations
yeah i think well
and i don't mean to dismiss like 500
years of fighting between protestants
and catholics but i kind of think that
at least between protestants and
catholics the works verse faith
dichotomy it's kind of a
misunderstanding
because i think we actually generally
agree in that
i certainly don't believe
that
the whole point of life is just to
intellectually assent
to the proposition
that jesus christ
is lord and and there is a god and you
know so people say that all you have to
do is believe in jesus all you have to
do is believe in god
i i definitely don't believe that
um
but
if we want to talk about faith okay well
you have to put your faith in god
that is more than an intellectual
exercise that is something that you do
with your whole
life and your whole
mind and soul and body that you're
investing
yourself in this belief and that that
includes works but it's not as though
you know you give a certain amount to
charity and you help old ladies across
the street you go to heaven it's not as
simple as that so it's kind of a it's
kind of a combination between the two
the way that i see it is it's sort of
like
um
you know if
if you if you if god is a is a bridge
into
into heaven into the afterlife um you
can't just walk up to the bridge and say
yes i believe that the bridge is there i
i assent to the existence of the bridge
and then just go and sit on the other
side of the bridge and not cross it you
actually have to
trust the bridge and and with your own
effort walk across it over the abyss
um
and so i think it's sort of
that's what faith is so when it comes to
your view of the afterlife what
cultivated that what where do you where
do you get your view of of heaven what
do you think heaven looks like and what
makes you believe that there is
something after we die
uh well you know i get it from my for my
faith primarily but um of course you
know when you read the the bible
um
there isn't a lot of in terms of a
description of what the afterlife is
actually going to look like and
and and everything that it entails so
you know i think if you look at if you
look at
you have to look at christian philosophy
through the ages and how they've sort of
developed uh this idea
um
one
for for me in terms of my my thinking
about the afterlife for me the most
influential
thing that i've read besides the bible
would be uh c.s lewis great divorce i
don't know if you've
read that um
i
i don't know how biblical it really is
but he
what i like about in that book is what
he does is he
he's able to really illustrate how it is
that a person might choose hell
instead of heaven because the only thing
that makes sense for me
um in terms of hell is
well it's not so much that god
sends you there even if you really want
to go to heaven god says no you know you
did this you did that that was wrong and
now you have to go
roast in the eternal fires for 50
trillion years
and then you haven't even started at
that point so that some
that sort of version has never really
made sense to me what does make sense
and what you'll hear christians say a
lot is well no god doesn't send you to
hell you choose it
okay
well all right then it seems more just
but what does it mean to choose hell how
could anyone ever choose hell when they
know that eternal joy is on offer
and anyway in the book a
great divorce he i think he does a good
job of showing what that might sort of
look like or why a person might actually
choose hell
rather than heaven and it all comes from
uh
are you interested are you able to find
joy outside of yourself or
have you only ever been able to figure
out how to pursue your own
interests and
if that's what it is if you're only
interested in yourself then god will say
okay well you want yourself that's all
you want that's all you love
then have yourself
in isolation for eternity that's what
you want yeah there there's a talmudic
tale that sort of says something similar
to tell me detail is that
there's a bunch of rabbis it's the
afterlife there's a bunch of rabbis
trying to figure out what's heaven and
what's hell and basically
hell is a bunch of people who are
sitting around a table and there's these
amazing foods that are on the table and
all that is in front of people are
spoons that are too long for them to
actually take the spoon and put it in
the food and get it to their mouth it's
too long they just can't reach it the
spoon is too lengthy and heaven is
they've is the people have realized that
the spoon is too long for their own
mouth so they're feeding each other so
it's the exact same thing but the idea
is that the perspective has shifted on
what's important
right it's let's look it's being able to
look
beyond yourself
and so the question that i always ask
myself and i was talking about
some people in my family about this
recently is uh
you know is it is it possible for
someone who
loves
anyone
to go to hell
um even if you have someone who
didn't you know didn't really believe in
god wasn't religious
but let's say they really did love their
wife and they really did love their
child not just that emotional affection
but actually love them
is it
is it possible even possible
metaphysically for that person to go to
hell uh considering that they have love
in them and if hell is a place where no
love can be then how could that person
be there
and uh
i guess it seems to me that
if you figure out how to love anyone
outside of yourself during your life
then
i think that's something god can take
and work with and those are little
embers of of something that he can
ignite into
uh a fire in a good sense
um so that's sort of the objective of
life is to is to love love and do what
you will uh is
augustine i think said that
it's a very very often uh i hear you
know christians say things like god is
love and the jew in me goes well he's a
little more than that uh what's what's
your take on the the sort of boiling
down of christianity to the to the sort
of trope that god is love what what does
that mean and what is that supposed to
mean or is there something beyond that i
think that that
statement is only problematic in our
society because we have such a absurd
view of what love is
uh a shallow view i should say we think
of love as just an emotional attachment
and so very often when we say we love
someone it's really about us what we
love about them we love about them is
how they make us feel
when we're with them but that's not
actually what love is love is uh
is it was aquinas that the love is is
willing the good of the other um
that's what it means to love someone a
very kind of simple way of looking at if
you really want what is best for them in
every sense spiritually as well and
you're going to work
as much as you can to to bring that help
them bring that about in their own life
and
then you love them and so
if we think of love in that sense um
number one as a choice as a
force of will
um
[Music]
then i think god is love kind of
works although i although i think maybe
it's just better to say god is all
loving
uh
maybe when you say god is love it just
becomes sort of love is god right
exactly right love is god it becomes a
sort of pantheistic thing we're all we
are all god ourselves if we love and you
know just weird stuff something god god
is loving is the best way of putting it
i think